الضمه ليله من جنيف الدكتور حسني عبيدي
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جنيف
دكتور عبيدي يعني ساعتين تقريبا
وتنتهي الهدنه التي اعلنتها روسيا من جانب
واحد هل ترى بان الغرض من هذه الهدنه قد
حققته روسيا
يعني
الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه باعتبار انها الرئيس
بوتين دائما يستمد بعض القيمه الروحيه
لاعطاء شرعيه لهذه الحرب ثم كذلك رئيس
بوتين اثبت للغرب هناك العديد من الاصوات
هنا تقول بان الرئيس بوتين لا يسيطر على
الحرب وانه كذلك يعني ابتعد عن ساحه الحرب
هو اراد يقول بان الكريم ما زال يسيطر على
على الاوضاع الميدانيه دليل على ذلك انه
يجب ان نعترف بان حدد العنف انخفضت مقارنه
مع الايام الاخيره لكن اكرمني من الاعلام
جيدا بان الغرب لن يعني يتلقى هذه
الاقتراح واا يمارس ايضا على كيف لي
احترام
البعض كان قدرهانا على تصدع داخل التحالف
الغربي الدعم لاوكرانيا خاصه مع حلول موسم
الشتاء كيف تنظر الى واقف الدول الغربيه
تجاه اوكرانيا
همم انا اعتقد ما زالت يعني الايام امامنا
لان فصل الشتاء ما زال واعتقد ذات الداعيه
صحيح الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه يمكن ان تحدث
تصدع هناك بوادر اختلاف همم وتباين بين
العديد من الدول الاوروبيه لكن في موضوع
الهدنه ومع تقريبا همم الهبات والمساعدات
العسكريه المهمه جدا من الجانب الفرنسي
والعلماني والامريكي والبريطاني من الصعب
جدا يحدث هناك شرح كبير داخل اوروبا
وعندما تتحدث على اوروبا يتحدث على اوروبا
العسكريه اوروبا الاطلسيه التي يمكن فعلا
ان تؤثر في مجرى الحرب فلا اعتقد انه يمكن
التعويل على هذا التباين في المواقف
الاوروبيه حتى ايطاليا التي يعني كانت في
الحمله الانتخابيه تراهن على هدنا مع
روسيا الان كذلك وقفت مع الموقف الامريكي
ثم انه نقطه الاخيره يعني انه الهدنه
تحتاج الى بعض الشروط اي ان بدون ضمانات
من الصعب جدا او بدون حتى مراقبين من
الصعب جدا ان تكون ناجح ويمكن البناء
عليها همم سياسيا لكن هي مبادره جيده حتى
وان كانت مناوره يعني الهدنه لا عيب فيها
ان تكون مناوره اذا كانت فعلا ان يمكن ان
تكون بدايه
لمسار سياسي يعني اذا انت ترى انه قد يكون
هناك افق لتوافق من اجل من هذه الازمه
هناك يعني
الوساطه التركيه او حتى دول اوروبيه اخرى
يمكن كذلك ان تقول بان لديها القدره همم
للمراهنه على قضيه هدنه لكن مختلفه هذه
المره يعني ان تكون هناك عدنا بمراقبين
سياسيين او بواساطه دوليه من اجل هدنه همم
ستكون انسانيه او هدنه كذلك سياسيه حتى
وان استمرت دعم العسكري لانه في نهايه وقف
اطلاق النار هذا يعني لا يتناقض مع
استمرار المعارك لكن على الاقل ان لا يكون
فقط مجرى الحرب مستمر دون ان تكون هناك اي
ديناميه سياسيه موازيه لهذا الدعم العسكري
الكبير الغربي